all right welcome to a new game 15
minute game on icc i'll go play you for
let's see what happens and all soaped
this technically runs well because i had
to reinstall my computer here and
everything's new here technically
alright so i'll go play this myth moral
gambit and this is some because on
that's a new book coming up on this myth
moral which is Sam quite interesting i
guess it's called mayhem in the mora i
guess i'll do a review on this soon
alright so i tried to play this in
gambit fashion here trying to Lou black
into to taking this pawn not that it is
so I'm so terrible but I think this is
recommended in the book I had a brief
look but not not an extensive look so
that I really know all this stuff
alright but now wonder about 5 45 yeah
shouldn't be too bad ladder see young
and we just retreats ok so should I now
just recap shonda for or queen bee three
queen bee three water immediately
threaten on f7 and maybe provoke him to
player e 6 which doesn't look like a
move from he wants to play or just
castles which also would be bad I'm not
sure about this will be 3 move I mean in
a way okay my plane i th six but I
thought maybe needs to play six anyway
to get the lighter developed at some
point
and after will be 36 at some point you
can play maybe 96 threaten queen 85 I
don't want that really so I'll just
cancel on you if you take some I have a
really great development so maybe night
age six now to get them to get closer to
castling ok so here voluntarily played
the smooth yeah i'd really like to get a
night quickly on the way to those
squares d 6 + f6 what about plane 9292
to you for not caring about a captcha on
c3 that looks dangerous okay come on
let's try this I don't think material is
so corneum all right let's go to this
great square on e form and I'm
controlling f6 and d6 no I think he's
some yeah forced to Castle now right and
now maybe Bishop g5 yeah this looks like
a good move
using the weakened dark squares don't
really need to spend time on recapturing
deform I think this this looks much
better going to the weakened squares
immediately maybe you should consider
age six now
he plays a move like night bc six i
think ur then maybe it's time to to
actually recap shown on d4 okay so this
is an interesting point here should
should I play Bishop age for keeping
this pin intact or should I play Bishop
f6 exchanging the bishop or even Knight
f6 not not without its points either are
white what about nine f6 king age 8 and
then quinte form that's not winning yet
but it's really close it's really close
Knight f6 look some quite tempting i
must admit
it does seem to to win immediately
though
alright so let's give this check and
decide later how to exactly continue it
I think it must be the rivals
yeah well it feels it feels like the
right move right down I might have known
at five which is our somewhat somewhat
awkward alright so let's um let's
calculate here what about a black Queen
d2 also also not not bad at all it's a
shame that Queen d4 doesn't seem to work
he's got nine f5 and maybe he can really
take it looks a very risky but maybe you
can do it
okay so I need to move the bishop most
likely don't see any sex working
immediately okay so I retreat this to it
to have form on f5 on ad on h4 I would
have had night f5 checking this piece
and this looks a bit awkward yeah still
has smiled on f6 is some a borrow some
peaceful black yeah does not have six
indeed looked empty maybe it wasn't the
best move some actually quite likely
that i had some some simple solution
okay decides to immediately get rid of
this piece quite understand the law so
should i take your guess oh ok let's
just take this
he spent lots of youth was this with
this light so what now is it does it pay
off to to ignore this recapture I mean I
can just take I'd have a good position
without any any troubles quindi two ways
and move on I like to I'd like to play
maybe you can even play g5 now it looks
it looks very nice for me g5 is a very
very weakening move or should I haven't
capture really I mean this is really the
symbol and good news yeah okay come on I
mean I've got every piece developed here
the bishops the special bear for nicely
it takes h6 so that i can play Queen d2
attack the spawn and the c-4 Bishop is
quicken being rerouted to d3 also
pointing towards the king so what here
Queen d2 provoking g5 yeah ok let's
detectives are thinking age 7 yeah ok
this is this actually I'm thought
wouldn't be possible but because now I
threaten a Bishop d3 at age 5 is just in
this diagonal which it's really a witch
spells trouble really
yeah okay they can check this but I want
to go to d3 anyway so he just missed
places tonight this move I would have
played them in any case and now this
night is a liability on a five he cannot
move the Queen for instance of course
you can try to play be six young
something like this developing but yeah
after h5 this looks like on you churn in
this initiative already
h5 is dangerous and the g6 some point is
so hard to to defend for black
yeah maybe still bc v6b 6p should be
seven I don't see em what else you
should do I mean black was clearly worse
anyway but after 95 it gets more than
critical yeah but if I recapture if I
caption now I can just take right and
play on yeah now now the a590 son is
hanging but f-for also so if I take a
five you can take f1 so it would be nice
to to move this Bishop preferably with
tempo so I check some some peace and
also a five is saying and yeah Bishop d6
looks good also Bishop b5 both them look
very very good for from me there should
be five I think he needs to go back back
all the way to d8 and then it's close to
ya h5 mh5 is working alone I mean both
moves lucky win let's go here actually
I'm interested in maybe taking this rook
so the possible rook takes f3 stuff is
not not available anymore
but both both moves art so Bishop b5
would have won I guess we have the
relatively best move now my PA 96 but
after a 5 h 5 Black is just exploding
ya know move really okay decided to move
the rope but now I can just take the
night right okay keep it simple nature
life resolves was also great yeah quick
win here for for the moral gambit yeah
it's actually fairly interesting opening
um I'll do this book review soon and
maybe I can can play this once in a
while I don't know really hit the line
so well but it's entertaining to play
yeah thanks for watching and I'll play
15 another 15 minute game soon I guess